[Music]
oh is this what is this here yo the
small world Streaker I didn't see that
what what is this oh man the ride yeah I
saw this dude's [__]
what this is a children's ride isn't it
oh yeah I mean this dude's probably high
out of his
mind
he looks like Curtis
Conor Curtis what you doing here
[Music]
man my man's just hanging out nah
just he's just doing what we're all
thinking I don't know why but I'm pick
picturing I'm picturing that thing that
he sat down in is like a one of those
Grinders oh and it just eats him I don't
know why but like it's a ride it feels
like it should have some crazy ass gears
like that that's working the animatronic
[__] he sits
down you know what I mean kids are like
ah
blood well the first video I saw of him
was he was getting out of the water on
the exterior and he's butt ass
naked so this is after this cuz his is
not wet yeah okay first I saw he just
turns the camera and his [__] little
meat is out that's horrendous yeah and
then bro the way they C him off they C
him off like a turkey why you can find
that it's so funny he's like they got
him you know cuffed up and they're
carrying him out like on his stomach
they got random Disney blankets on them
to cover him up okay and they're
carrying them out like stomach down legs
in the
air they each got a limb H damn it's
almost a worse image
damn it's crazy because Disneyland has
like underground um passageways on some
rides so you think he's just [__]
high out of his mind tripping on some
[__] and was like let's do all yeah he's
probably just [__] PCP or something
he's just walking around the
ride so casual excuse me excuse
me pardon me sorry pardon me sir the
ride you if I just squeeze past your
boat also crazy to go in that water you
got to have a [__] parasite that's
just sitting water they they probably
haven't changed that water in like
decades n not since 1920 yeah here we go
here we go look at this look look where
they're dragging him
out oh my god
dude he's still tripping too he's like
I'm
flying I'm fine it is real magic is real
it is the most magical place on Earth
you know what's crazy this dude woke up
that morning going yeah I'm just going
to I don't know I'm just going to micro
do and hit Disneyland yeah yeah what are
you doing today I'm going to drop AET
and go to Disneyland whoa that sounds
awesome I like yo that's crazy I don't
know if I do that you're wild he's in
jail right now like I did what yeah
exactly I'm a sex offender yeah yeah
what no dude I no
I just was trying to trip balls and
[__] yeah it's so funny how casual he
is like he just has no idea he's doing
anything
wrong this goes back to that thing I was
saying when that [__] up when I was
saying if you do something in public
that just gets you five GTA like social
stars like this is one of those it's so
funny they just sit on the boat and look
over and go yeah I'm doing it yeah yeah
yeah yeah
immediately as soon as your shirt comes
off
B yeah the army's coming bro yeah yeah
dude you get the [__] yeah there's a
tank in front of Disneyland man it's
going to shoot you in the [__]
face dang man taking a little dip butt
ass naked oh we went to um we went to
Disney C in
Tokyo cuz the tickets were 60 bucks
Disneyland in what's Disney C it's like
their California Adventure basically
okay but it's it's like part of the park
is on the water oh nice it's Disney c
yeah oh was Disney c yeah it's [__]
Disney [__]
Disney oh man so was it cool that looks
sick as hell it's pretty like visually
impressive yeah they got this man-made
lake oh yeah that's like the penis cat
[__] I
mean yeah I was streaking illegal there
yeah [__] you
got yeah we saw a Streaker and our whole
crew was like oh you beat us to it
yeah um yeah that penis castle was crazy
horrifying there there are people that's
so scary yeah that [__] so I went there
I was doing hell of Photography there I
got this new camera I'm such a I'm such
a like copycat and nerd yeah I'm both
I bought this camera for Alina and I
helped her fire a few shots on it before
we left and I go this camera is so sick
I bought it for myself no way really
she's like why' you buy my gift for my
yourself I don't know we were both going
ham on it but um uh I was going to say
Disneyland in Japan is
uh when people go it seems It's not
a they take it serious they go like
either in couples or groups and and most
of them are matching
matching like planned outfits okay there
were groups of people that looked like
J-pop groups they were so coordinated
damn I don't know it's just a thing
that's cool it's interesting well I
would do that yeah so what's funny is
our friend we were in we were in line
for some of the rides and the weights
were like two and a half hours oh yeah
[__] that but they had single Rider
lines okay and he goes bro why the [__]
let's just go single we're like yeah
true right to the front every time damn
and then could you go on together no but
we're like we just ride it and we talk
about it
afterward there weren't that many rides
cuz the Disney SE part's kind of small
but um what's crazy is the lines for the
food were longer than the rides really
at Disney was the food good did you get
anything we
didn't well we got some food we got some
fried chicken there it was insane
actually yeah that's what I'm talking
about yeah it actually was insane we
got oh they have look up Disney C little
green
guys
dessert see now we're talking dude I got
to go back to Disneyland I might drop
acid and go to
yeah I've heard it's [__]
awesome I've heard the cown is terrible
though like charges and have go to court
yeah yeah oh these little [__] yeah
these little [__] yeah they serve
them as food oh nice you can eat these
little [__] when I saw the array of
these guys I wanted to buy like a
hundred and just throw them on the floor
I just wanted to step on them I don't
know
why yeah there's something about it
makes you want to kill all of them yeah
the CL squeeze
them